since we actually um we're introduced to
the idea of sets I actually snuck them
into the very end of fractals what was
the second last well is the second last
fractal that I showed you is the most
complicated one of all there's the
Mandelbrot set wonder if you'll be
saying that right so sets right a set is
the first kind of on turn right that's
that's the first idea and the way we do
notice that is really raises this okay
you're probably not very good at drawing
curly braces because we don't do them
very often and they should look like
this it's easier you'll get practice in
a way just like when you see something
like this okay you know that there's a
coordinate right we're used to that kind
of thing and so when you see curly
braces
Figg a set okay so you would put things
inside here so a definition of a set all
it is is well how would you define a set
because you've used this language
informally before no sarahfey
as a word that's interesting that's
interesting because um well why wouldn't
have so many meanings yeah even
volleyball anyway a set is it's a
collection of elements a collection or a
group of your life of elements I'm
actually going to avoid the word group
because in maths
groove means something else as well okay
you could say a collection of items but
in set theory we actually call it that
they're supposed to be called
elements right objects or items for
things that can fit in here we can put
them all together okay so an example
give you a give you a couple okay for
instance I could give you this that's
exempt an example of a set right oh this
set is a finite set right I'm gonna
throw out occasionally some words which
you don't need to devote a whole road to
but they're important so sheep exam
let's finite okay but you don't have to
just have a finite set you could have it
infinite set right you could go on
forever for instance this is the set of
all odd numbers and it goes on forever
okay sets can also include sets within
them as elements but we don't go into
that have been random okay um diagrams
that over here we're very familiar with
the main kind of diagram used to
illustrate sets like this and they're
named after guy with video you know it
is Venn diagrams all right now so long
the piece come in
sorry where were we a Venn diagram Venn
diagrams now we're very familiar with
these kinds of things right that second
one on that um this is this is the
typical Venn diagram as you will see as
we move through these right Venn
diagrams are anything which represent a
bunch of sets that relate to each other
that's all okay so for something like
this okay
these two sets he's actually an
important work we've introduced this
idea of a finite set and an infinite set
another word for you which is not worth
putting on its own row is that these two
sets the ones I've named they're what we
call disjoint sets right this joint sets
which you might be able to tell based on
this example what does that mean
destroyed sets it means they have
nothing in common with each other no
overlap whatsoever so if I were to draw
a Venn diagram to illustrate these two
sets of how they relate to each other
well it'd be pretty boring it would look
like this because these are not
destroyed of it you just have to
separate mumbles that's it okay so there
you go simple right
okay now where it starts to get
interesting is as I said when you've got
more than one set together and they
relate in some way okay so here's our
first important way to connect sets
together which is intersection okay
there's a key word for this switches and
and the symbol that we use for it sets
tend to be denoted by our capital
letters ok so if I wrote this a and then
I draw this arch kind of shape okay so
it's not quite it's nice it's not a
semicircle okay it's kind of it's kind
of smaller than that it's kind of like a
upside-down u without the without the
tail II didn't
we'll get to that in a second with it so
intersection means well what do you
think the word indicates it means that
yet is a anterior this a is a bunch of
elements that are in both sets
okay so intersection I would say it's
the elements both in this case set a and
something
objects for elements that belong in both
sets so let's give an example okay let's
say if I gave you this I'll go back to
this again soon for suits we'll call
that one eight and let's sit out another
one that's called B hmm let's go B all
the prime numbers under 10 what are all
the prime numbers under 10 you got two
three five and seven okay cool so you
can see here this is a little
interesting there is an overlap between
these if I said a intersection to be
right or a and B at the same time okay
which objects are in there it's just two
to is the only number that's in both of
them okay so I would say like this okay
the intersection of two sets is also a
set sense why I've got curly braces
around oh let's draw a quick diagram
intersection would be this area
now the Big Brother to intersection is
Union okay now just like intersection is
keyword and the Union also has a keyword
I'll let you think about what it is in a
second okay now the the symbol floor
Union is the upside-down symbol of
intersection so it actually does look
like a you just without Taylor okay
that's one of the ways you can remember
which ones which
this one looks like literally Union
right now that looks kind of like to
section I don't know it's a bit of a
stretch but it works sure the keyword
fair this was and Union means give me
everything in both sets okay so the key
word for that would be or right
hey all being right if it's one or the
other no big deal right so this would be
not just elements in bird set right this
would be elements in in sit a horse Fe
that's all see I'm using the key word
there you see it set or set oh okay so
again if I just use the same a and B
that I did here right then a union B
will be equal to well it's gonna be two
all the way up to seven
seven by the way just to know I wrote
this right but I could equally have
written this seven six five four three
two okay or I could have written two new
four six three five seven
okay the idea is that what it doesn't
matter or it doesn't matter these two
and this is an important idea these two
are equal sets they are the same set
right if water is important to you then
you do not have a set you have what word
do we use when things have an order to
them also starts with us our secrets I
want things to be sequential things like
Sabre Fibonacci sequence right it's not
the Fibonacci set who cares about that
that's not very meaningful but when
you've got the middle order then it's
interesting since we don't care where
they are okay so these two an EP sense
let's draw a diagram if you got two
overlapping like this what would the
Union be yeah you color in you color in
both circles fully okay I am about to
run out of space but hopefully you've
got a bit more to go we have lots more
ideas but the next one is called a and
there is a couple of different symbols
for this okay so that first one is a
triangle it's actually a capital Delta
or you might also see this it's a circle
that's hard
okay
the two just like it's got two symbols
it also has two names and they're both
pretty cool I think okay I'm first year
at the full name like this so this is
called the symmetric difference right
that's a pretty fancy name okay this and
this or the key phrase for this keyword
is X okay it's not red
Zor its x4 okay the X is an initial it
stands for exclusive okay
now here's what I'm going to do we're so
happy going across the arm across the
table I'm going to draw this for you and
I want you to tell me how you define
this okay it's not the intersection it's
not the Union the symmetric difference
or the exclusive ball looks like this
this this would be a triangle or a X or
B how are you yeah
good yeah
so you can see that it's it's one or the
other but it's exclusive right it's it's
exclusively a or it's exclusively B it's
not both at the same time okay yep these
both mean the same thing
it's just that you'll see this C set
theory is a really interesting and
wide-ranging topic so lots of people use
it and when in you and whenever you've
got lots of people using the same kinds
of ideas they always make up their own
notation okay
the same thing will happen when you guys
get into calculus most of you next year
because so do we use calculus it was a
different way of writing which is
frustrating but once you get the Havers
so we would say elements in you can say
this two ways one way you could say is
in a high bar set a or set B but not
both
okay or you can say elements in
exclusively today or dissolution
separate it both singing okay so what
would a xor be equal to I'm going with
this as a babe yeah that's right because
two is this number in the middle right
just like I said in here
oh now can you see what Maurice tiny get
some relationships between the things in
this table right it's going to be let's
see three four five six seven
really it's this the union - the
intersection I mean you can even see
that visually right this is this - this
right so you can say it's a union B
minus a intersection make sense